so you might be keeping up with the
fashion but they don't care they want
the old school inside so me you might go
there your big old titties and your and
your big old ass but I can catch you man
with my flat breast and my flat ass why
cuz I can cook clean and I'm submissive
and I can look lucky I'm not luck it's
not luck not luck care no it is not luck
I did not come like this because of luck
it pisses me off when people say luck I
didn't get like this because of luck
this is who I am this is good parents
good uping for women good upbringing for
man this is not listening to stupid
women this is listening to older men
older women is support me this a got
nothing to do with luck this is to do
with hard work and determination I'm not
going and paying your money to get your
outside fixed up when you need to pay
your money to get your inside fixed up